welcome to this video playing hard a
hard eight almost John Arne Nielsen okay
it's nice that they give you this ten
seconds now at the start so I can
readily check the flag and stuff like
that okay is playing the g3 line against
the NIMS oh oops that's not very common
actually taking them hum ok
hmm yeah just just a bit strange how do
i place this but ok you can do it it's
not not bad or anything just just a bit
term unconventional ok do I go I'd
wonder castles knights you fry if it's a
bit annoying ok I'm doing this back just
just to prevent anything happening there
how do I total play this d 6 I can get
in d6 mission bay 3 is very quick there
ok let's start with that Bishop f4 i
have e 5
yeah it looks like decent control the
c-4 point is obviously very weak so if I
am I'm not allowing anything and very
young specific like having something
attacking then that should be in very
nice shape in this position these six to
fix this fix the porn on the C file on
c4 and on the sea hard on c4 okay be 64
bishop a 6 & 9 a-5 so I'm just trying to
win this pawn let's see if he goes you
can try something like f4 f5 this kind
of thing but this always gives me a
higher it looks it actually looks like a
nice position I don't really believe
that white has enough dynamic play for
this pawn that you will be losing yeah
this this pawn will be lost Bishop a 64
95
95 yeah I'm okay I might have creative
form so let's go there I and Queen oh I
didn't think about that move at all
which I should have I really should have
thought about it probably not not not
not fatal or anything but I simply
didn't take it into account so okay if I
go to e7 about okay Bishop f4 is not
dangerous right he gets to play C 5
which is which is a better way to lose
the pawn in comparison to what what was
possible yeah so I shouldn't have run
into this tactic am not a good idea I
can play c5 now which is victim
irritating
there I shouldn't have run into the c-5m
where was a better bad play yeah this is
not this is not not clear at all not at
all even questionable if I should take
the pawn in the first place takes Queen
a4 is this is this is kind of kind of
annoying this kind of situation okay
let's try to use the the weekend squares
maybe I can get the porn here and not
the point the bishop sorry I might get
the bishop to trade okay so it takes
Knight takes he's got this quite
annoying made threat and f6e will just
drop back all the way to see one
night a three and then checking on g
five matches that's probably not a good
idea if sick f6 is a very weakening move
I don't really want that when g6 also
weakens admittedly but um I Queen a4a I
also at Queen a form this was maybe even
more problematic hmm I don't know yeah I
never should have allowed to 5 i'm don't
do that i think he's in a really
terrible position or let's say a
terrible is maybe too strong word I'd
load excellent for luck he is definitely
the worst is definitely over frame it's
got an active get you got some activity
here night be too what is the move after
night be to show me
I said some technique I don't know
doesn't doesn't look like i'm
overlooking the simplest murcia queen
each form as simple as that I didn't see
it at all which makes not be too
completely ridiculous ready now wow ok I
could have just taken d 5 nights Quincy
6 or whatever and I'm totally ok ok is
threatening on g6 now so I have to check
here I guess time morning
it's probably still okay somehow but
this others I don't know I have to play
a one at least hang with check some
rookie five looked a bit strange
yeah looks like and winning huge
material now yeah this fork on the rocks
Jeff's no move him look somebody to e1 I
can take with the Queen only five which
is trading everything yeah i was a bit
lucky i mean i think initially i was in
a really good position and then I
allowed all this activity and then he
probably was better okay I can take a
five which I mean okay this chest and
then he I are covering g6 check
check and I ok has got this check so i
can i can return some stuff this is
covered maybe here i am white forfeits
on time yeah well allowing 'if I've was
a bad idea truly this is around here
this is a position that this is almost
winning for black because I win the pawn
without any compensation I just have to
avoid this is donny five move which is
which is really bad to allow that so i
should i should go to e5 after all I was
irritated by Queen a forward i can take
with the bishop as well this this i
didn't take into a car i was always
planning to take with the night but i
can also just play him somewhere like
this and he's just sitting on this this
week s which will fall I mean he's got
no compensation I mean for the pawn and
he's he will stay with a bad structure
and this is just unnecessary to allow I
mean even ok computer actually doesn't
mind and says that young I'm also about
about winning mmm why exactly
here because I can take with the night a
cold-blooded play as usual yeah I'm
threatening this this is very important
after night year I have this
intermediate move and it's also better
to go to d8 yeah so then maybe it wasn't
that bad but here he all of a sudden got
some some very decent activity for his
pieces yeah here Queen a4 was strong no
he didn't see that one I mean of course
I am me neither but Rupert g7 and Queen
Essex it's a bit much why this winning
so many many mistakes here here took
maybe f6 is better I don't know yeah
push on here is good here yeah and now
I'll night be too I mean I should have
this sequin age for what I was I wanted
to do this originally and this is just
okay i can i can force the the trade now
and this is a very nice end game where
this night is protecting my two
weaknesses and I can play a NC spawns
this is a very one-sided issue he
probably should hold but it's very nice
for black and this is just ridiculous
yeah I didn't see creates fight on I
don't know what this is the computer now
has 94 with the draw okay there is a
counter-attack that is at least a
perpetual but ok this is this now rook
t6 supposed to be equal that this is
losing after this is this is losing
losing the house there was a bit lucky
that he went into that but at least them
I wasn't I wasn't the worst yeah I mean
I was really thinking much worse but
this seems to hoard may I rook g6 is a
threat so I have to do something Quincy
to is the the computer computer
suggestion
or roxy 7 yeah that would have been very
tricky with little time ok thanks for
watching